so last night I'm watching TV okay I'm
watching football Sunday it's football
well it's Tuesday now so two days ago I
was watching football because the series
right right you know what I mean yeah uh
and I'm watching and I say oh an all-new
this show coming up followed by this
show followed by this show and this show
an all-new number one show of NBC and I
looked at my friend next to me and I go
I never want to do any of those shows
ever ever No ever no and
you know but if you would have rewound
years before and I wasn't working and I
I had a family or whatever I'd be like
I'd love to be on any of those shows
yeah but thankfully you get you know
there's a time when you can you can
choose right but do you feel like you
can choose a lot more lately I mean
because doing Parenthood for years yeah
that probably helped you a lot you had a
little Nest Egg yes and this and that
and some things that give you a little
bit of a nesting then you do passion
projects like handmaid's tale which
you're probably not getting paid a ton
because it's HBO and you're just lucky
to be on that show you know they make
you feel like that like oh this is HBO
we're not going to pay it yeah you just
you're lucky you're on this show yeah
Hulu oh it's Hulu yeah handmaid's Tales
Hulu yeah yeah sorry it's one of those
but you know what I mean yeah but um I
don't know where I was going with this
but sort of like do you get to do you
are you choosy are your agents like what
about this what about that and you're
like why are you sending me this it's
not what I want to do are you able to do
that I can do that a little more but you
know now the parameters are you know I I
was on the way out I was all it takes is
standing in customs for a couple hours
to for me to have a life crisis and you
know I emailed my team I was like hey
guys I can't work and I can't work in
Canada again uh not this year just
because I've been away from my family
for most of coven my wife is tackling
taking on three Maniacs at home and and
uh that's a lot it's a lot and I want to
be so if we can find a job that works in
town great even in the states great you
know and uh you know that said there's
very few jobs like that and and not for
nothing but you know I'm at a point
where I I'm never gonna I thought I was
gonna stop competing but there's there's
always other actors you know even in our
our ages it never ends and now it's
because television is where it's at I I
compete against bigger name film stars
so
you know there's a there's a a a
kind of a sweet spot where I'm reside
where people are like well we can't get
this guy but we can get this guy I've
always been that guy they can't get this
guy so let's give it to that guy or this
guy we're firing so let's hire this guy
totally which is you know which is fine
it's a great project you know sometimes
you luck out you're like oh man I'm glad
I did that totally it was funny I was
talking with uh Lizzy uh Elizabeth Moss
on on handmaid's tale and I said you
know what's funny is uh I uh I don't
know if you've had this experience but I
I there have been moments where I've
been only a few times have I been
offered a role but it was after they had
offered to someone else and I I lucked
into being you know I I was nosy and I
was like hey who who was the who was the
first guy offered and and um in one
instance it was Owen Wilson and the
other instance yeah yeah and the other
instance it was um Ewan McGregor I
thought well geez if I'm getting their
sloppy sucks I'm doing pretty good yeah
yeah I'd say so yeah and and Lizzy goes
oh yeah once
um uh there was a job that uh uh Kate
Winslet couldn't do and they offered me
and I was like sure I was like wow yeah
okay I guess I'm not to that level but
that's pretty sweet yeah Okay cool so
there's all these tiers of you know yeah
you know we're you know it's tough
though because you're right they don't
but there's not a lot of I mean most
things shoot somewhere else because the
tax benefits right right so they shoot
now shooting Nashville North Carolina
and Louisiana and all these places that
you know it's just easier so but you're
still away from your family yeah and
it's tough yeah definitely tough
foreign